in a volatile world the solar harvest
beats every other source of energy the
cheapest electricity and the quickest
way of replacing russian gas with clean
secure power and yet the government's
energy strategy gave top billing and
strongest commitments to wind and
nuclear
we were disappointed that the government
didn't come out with a concrete target
if you want to move quickly solar is
your best option hinckley points about
2.5 gigawatts if memory serves we've got
about seven gigawatts of solar that we
could feasibly get built and and start
exporting in the next two years um so
really quick turnaround for basically
three times the the reward the uk now
has 14 gigawatts of solar generating
capacity the government hopes that will
increase by up to five times by 2035
but the energy strategy set bolder more
comprehensive targets for eight nuclear
reactors and 50 gigawatts of wind
turbines that's despite solar's
advantage
the price of solar has fallen 85
over the last decade it now costs 50
pounds to generate enough electricity to
supply 2 000 homes for one hour but
compare that to gas where it's 200 and
the bigger the project the cheaper it
gets
in cambridgeshire plans have been
submitted for the biggest solar farm yet
more than a million panels spread over
the equivalent of two and a half
thousand football pitches but this is
fertile land good for growing crops and
local farmer nick says food security
matters too
for not a moment are we
anti-solar we're anti-bad solar in the
uk we have six hundred thousand acres of
south-facing industrial roof space which
is unused we have brownfield sites we
have
arable land that is less efficient less
versatile than this that and we feel
that yet we're taking out here a prime
prime um quality soil which shouldn't
should not be used for solar
this is the biggest breakthrough in
solar technology in decades
in oxford scientists are about to start
production of a new type of solar panel
by adding a mineral called perovskite
they can generate 20
more electricity and in future their
panels could double the output of
anything available today
having more energy more power coming
from the same
areas means that
in the same we can reduce
the areas where we can put those panels
for the same power output
we can use restricted space urban spaces
rooftops
we will need much less space of that to
generate enough power to to fill the
the country from the sun
the government says it's considering
changes to the planning rules to
accelerate the growth of solar it will
mean significant changes to the
landscape and while some see light
others fear blight thomas more sky news